[Music]
hello and welcome to this video yeah
this video is about the Sicilian Rosalie
mo variation that is after a 4 C 5 93 96
our choice to play B should be 5 this
should be 5 is Russell mo variation
Bishop b5 nowadays is probably the main
line in this position which is quite
interesting to note because usually it
is always said that the open Sicilian is
the critical choice basically no matter
what black it's doing on move to however
after knight c6 on the second move white
players more and more shift towards this
move in order to avoid some lights in
the open Sicilian that they currently
have trouble finding any advantage
against this is most notably the
sveshnikov yeah just to show you what
I'm talking about
especially core variation is this line
and white struggles to find anything
there this is not the only reason but
the main reason why people more and more
are shifted towards exploring Bishop b5
and there should be 5 is not just an
avoidance move let's say that avoids
something but it's rather interesting in
its own right um with this should be 5
we play a very sound healthy developing
move and prepare castling this is some
very fundamental thing to mention but
you have to see that black is not really
working on its kingside development the
whole King site is not to develop at all
and we are going to be most of the time
cancelling on move 4 so our King will be
very safe and we have a very sound
development the Bishop on b5 is also
taking a look at this Bishop so in some
cases we will actually take on c6 and
give up the bishop pair this is a
feature especially if black
provokes this caption we're not going to
take there voluntarily all that much but
if black plays a six for example we will
capture on six but we will get something
in return for giving up the bishop as we
will see the whole setup that white is
after is very fundamentally sound
oftentimes our next moves are castles
look to e1 and potentially C 3 and d 4
to expand in the center um black after
Bishop b5 has an extremely wide range of
moves black has tried I mean like
everything under the Sun but don't feel
too intimidated there are actually only
two maybe three main lines that need to
be studied in some detail the main lines
here are the most g6 probably the most
popular the movie six both very logical
because black needs to develop the
kingside in some way and this Bishop on
f8 needs some space and the third move
that is also played quite frequently is
d6 d6 prepares Bishop to d7 in order to
recapture with the bishop and only later
develop the King side the other idea of
d6 is also that it stops whites from
advancing if five so that Knight f6
becomes more of an option
those are by far the main moves against
the offbeat tries and we're going to
look at them in the next couple of
minutes just playing healthy move is
totally fine and enough for having a
slight advantage but it pays off to know
some details because you in fact get
those quite a bit on the lower levels if
you're not playing in a GM tournament
and most of you won't so take a look at
the rare moves
knowing how to punish them can be quite
helpful so let's have a
look at some of the rare moves first and
then work towards the main continuations
um in this position black sometimes
tries to avoid any doubling of pawns by
playing the Queen let's start with those
twin to c7 doesn't move that is Israel
that's rare still but it's played often
again by players who want to simply make
sure that they won't get any doubled
pawn on the C file however it is slow
their black is not developing a minor
piece and does not prepare castling okay
we are going to cancel and now black
most of the time continues with the move
a6 that is the most consistent way of
doing this I get the bishop arrow okay
we are happy to take because it's the
quickest move in a way we don't want to
retreat to a meter square like YouTube
so we take in this position probably the
relatively best choice not great who
black but the relatively best choice is
probably to take with the D pawn this is
I'm not very logical in its own right
yeah why do all this and then take with
the D pawn it's just that they're taking
with the Queen turns out to be extremely
risky this is also better for white D
takes but black at least won't get
checkmated quickly which could happen
after Queen takes this position we will
actually look at via the move three a6
this is some yeah what we're going to
look at in just a minute so just hang on
I'm going to show you what happens after
D takes c6 shortly so Queen takes is
seen more often and we just play Knight
c3 develop this Knight and cover before
in the process not that we would be very
afraid of like taking this pawn and
further delay in development but Nancy's
free is logical anyway so a six and here
very important we need to open up the
center now and exploit that black is
completely undeveloped so d4
a good move develop the next moves would
be something like a Bishop f4 d5 if
black does not stake but usually they do
so black takes Queen takes is also not
bad but knight takes is very logical win
another tempo Queen to c7 and now a
simple move like rook e1 leads to a
really really great position for white
the issue is that black can hardly
develop Knight f6 is answered by E 5 and
this is where's the night going now and
we have ideas like twin to G form bring
the bishop to g3 to attack the Queen
I mean black it's like three Tempe down
and it will be very tough for him to
avoid an opening disaster him the move
Queen c7 is in fact very risky due to
this line a similar move is to move
Queen to b6 this is trying to do the
same thing to recapture with the Queen
but attack the bishop first so I suggest
to play 93 simply cover the bishop and
now black most of the time
place the move ecigs this is quite
logical as the move Knight e5 is always
in the air as Queen takes b5 is answered
by this four
so if six makes sense it's by far the
most popular move b6 and now I suggest
to play move that probably will surprise
you a little bit I suggest to simply
take on c6 even though black has not
played to move a6 and suggests to take
the reason is that if we instead would
Castle 94 is a little bit of an
annoyance yeah it is a little bit
problematic to face the move Knight g4
in a situation where the night is on c3
here we couldn't even take as Knight
takes he takes we lose material so I
suggest to simply take on c6 and black
now takes with the Queen most of the
time if he should decide to take with a
pawn then
after castles our development is
excellent I just wanted to show one
particular plan if black plays something
like define in such a position you
should be very much to recognizing that
those pawns and particular c5 is quite a
weak something like d3 in this position
will lead to some substantial issues for
black it looks very tame what white is
doing but we got tonight a 4 B 3 Bishop
a three to put lots of pressure on that
pawn and in fact quite often this point
will just get lost they can now time to
cover that so this is a typical idea
that you might know from the
nimzo-indian defense in fact you can
easily say that this is an image of
Indian Defence reversed with white
having about three extra template where
one move and the Queen moved around
quite uselessly so it says pretty nice
for white the c8 Bishop will be a
problem for a long time I hope you
enjoyed this preview of the keep it
simple
efore repertoire you can get the full
course on chasuble comm which features
the move trainer that makes it easy and
simple to learn all the nice and
remember them and all the lights are
chosen with one thing in mind
keep it simple for you and make it
difficult for your opponent
[Music]
you